what do you get when you mix an eagle a
stork and a bad hair day it's the
secretary bird perhaps the strangest
avian in all of Africa
weirdly for a bird of prey it spends its
time hunting on the ground in a totally
badass way as it scrolls through the
savanna it keeps its eye out for insects
and lizards and even snakes but
typically it doesn't Peck them to death
no it kicks the ever-loving crap out of
them like so let's get some dramatic
music for this slo-mo
oh yeah
as you can see this bird has some
serious reach after all it's four feet
tall
it's crazy powerful too it can kick with
a force over five times its own body
weight that's particularly impressive
when you consider the bird isn't getting
a running start with a kick the strike
is so quick the foot only contacts prey
for 10 milliseconds that's handy when
hunting snakes at an extra precaution
those legs are heavily scaled in case
something tries to fight back so can the
secretary bird kick it yes it can
90s hip-hop reference